le secteur des technologies vous savez
toujours mouvement et c'est pas en 2020
que cette tendance va s'arrêter ou
diminue et on en parle avec pascal
forget les chroniqueur à l'émission
planète techno serait il s'exposera
bonjour pascal ou pourquoi pas alors là
vous avez quelque chose à faire son
entrée en ondes alors c'est quoi la
nouvelle tendance là des cellulaires à
deux écrans
oui puisqu'on veut un téléphone avec le
plus grand écran possible le moment
donné ça devient trop grand pour entrer
dans sa poche alors ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on met deux écrans on le puits on le
met dans sa poche ça prend moins de
place et on peut afficher deux choses en
même temps soit une page web
ces messages on peut faire une
conversation vidéo avec quelqu'un en
continuant de jouer discrètement dans
l'autre écran est à peu près toutes les
compagnies annoncent des appareils comme
ça samsung lg ou à louer
même microsoft va avoir des laptops avec
deux écrans ce qui va permettre de
partager son contenu rester compact et
permettent d'entrer dans sa poche on va
même avoir le retour du razer le fameux
téléphone philippe way du début des
années 2000 tchèque
ouais le téléphone qu'ils se pliaient
maintenance relancer l'intérêt c'est
l'écran va se plier comme un
portefeuille et donc on va voir un petit
téléphone dans la poche mais qui va
s'ouvrir pour avoir un grand écran alors
faut s'attendre à en voir de plus en
plus c'est un gel pense que ça va être
quelque chose que les manufacturiers
vont pousser est-ce que ça va être
populaire ce que l'an prochain on va se
dire finalement c'est un flop on le sait
pas mais on voit l'intérêt que suscitent
ses selles échange on va rester un peu
dans les écrans parce que en 2019 on a
beaucoup parlé des assistants vocaux
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont su pour noël
c'est un non on a vu apparaître au cours
de l'année des instants vocaux avec
écran moi je trouve ça change
complètement l'interaction qu'on a avec
l'objet au lieu de parler avec une tour
qui nous répond on peut voir des
informations affichées sur l'écran
si on demande la météo on voit la météo
on peut demander des photos des gens
peut faire des on peut regarder des
vidéos on peut le thé le vidéo visant
son téléphone on peut le pousser dans
son petit écran et le regarder sur son
psy qui sont fédérées sénat on peut voir
la recette s'afficher sur son petit
écran
une table c'est comme une tablette donc
les tablettes sont en baisse de ventes
mais ces petits écrans l'eau sur le coin
de ça q et son comptoir de cuisine
ajoute beaucoup interactions et ça
permet surtout de faire des appels vidéo
avec quelqu'un dont on compte la
pelleteuse sonne c'est comme un
téléphone avant on avait un téléphone à
fils dans le coin de la cuisine
maintenant on a son petit écran qui
permet de faire des appels vidéo avec
quelqu'un pendant qu'on a les mains
occupées en train de faire la cuisine
par exemple on va parler d'une
révolution quand même des dernières
années dans les écouteurs on commence à
voir les gens qui ont toujours un bidule
dans l'oreille on sait pas trop quelle
forme quelle saveur on éliminer les
faits l'ont imité on élimine le bruit on
élimine le bruit bay a décrit un post
prod apports des petits écouteurs ici
que ceux qui essayent c'est son cher son
cher sucre est désormais attendu à tuer
de payer ainsi plus pour les appareils
mais dans les impôts de proue on ajoute
l'annulation de rhuys qui est maintenant
pas mal la norme dans tous les écouteurs
sans fil parce que les prises
d'écouteurs disparaissent de téléphone
les gens qui s'attendent à brancher vont
parfois la mauvaise surprise de voir que
peu de prise d'écouteurs fois un petit
adaptateur compères donc des écouteurs
sans fil s'imposer les faits d' annuler
le bruit ambiant c'est vraiment vraiment
chouette on vous confie quelque chose de
ces chers et problème c'est petit et on
les perdait malheureusement moi j'ai
perdu une première version
alors je m'en mords les doigts en faveur
des anciens os x leopard ya d'autres
modèles moins coûteux qui sont
similaires qui ont des fonctions
semblables mais ça s'impose pas mal les
écouteurs sans fil en 2020 dont par
l'ondé netflix et bio à apporter plus
dit ce n'est plus juste il est nommé
prendrait cinq minutes alors tout ça ça
il y en a plusieurs qui ont été lancés
en 2019 a introduit ce n'est plus bon on
se retrouve roulades dans la
vraiment que ce service d'abonnement on
va se retrouver particulièrement se
distendent oui à 20 ont changé de chaîne
à la télévision maintenant on change de
services carrément ce qui est un peu
complexe et beaucoup de télé
intelligente qui étaient à la mode il ya
quelques années qu'ils sont pauvres qui
n'ont pas été mises à jour qui acceptent
pas si nouveau service là donc on a
besoin d'ajouter une petite boîte son
téléviseur comme au cul ou comcast qui
permet de diffuser ses différents
services mettre à jour sa petite boîte
s'assurer que le service est compatible
ça devient un beau casse tête pour le
consommateur la chose qu'il faut se dire
c'est qu'on n'est pas obligé de
s'abonner à tous ces services là de la
même manière qu'on n'était pas obligé de
ses abonnés au bouquet tout équipés du
câble à l'époque mais oui il va falloir
faire des choix pour acheter du contenu
légal
il ya du contenu télévisuel légale dans
son ordinateur par le web
non ça c'est un avant-goût a fait de ce
que vous pouvez voir dans votre boule de
cristal pour les prochains mois ce qu'on
va surveiller particulièrement mais là
vous partez côté de las vegas en volant
ce vaisseau grand messe des maillots
logis et on va voir des choses
particulières parce que le silence n'est
plus ce qu'il était avant c'était des
grosses oui il peut être pas si c'était
des grosses entreprises qui dévoilait
des choses maintenant c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de startups de petites
entreprises en démarrage
maintenant l'automobile s'est invité
donc les automobiles maintenant on met à
jour son véhicule pour bénéficier de
nouvelles fonctions l'alimentation
maintenant est aussi mince en omettant
les viandes les fausses viande qui
s'installe on peut y goûter le boss qui
va retenir l'attention sur je pense que
l'intégration de la domotique
ça va commencer à être pour ouvrir le
sac j'ai évidemment la connexion plus
rapide
l'informatique ambiante le fait que ça
disparaît dans son
son domicile de d'entrée par l'epic tous
allumé je pense à se concrétiser cette
année mais évidemment c'est comme
l'alimentation en pilule c'est toujours
l'autre voie lente alimentation là il ya
des choses qu'on n'a pas craqué on
l'attend quand on vous laisse aller
merci beaucoup pour cet arrêt on va
suivre bien sûr vos chroniques entre
autres sur ici explorera et de cette
visite du côté de las vegas ce sera
intéressant de voir ce qui va en
ressortir merci beaucoup pas de version